at number 11 it's a fantastic clip this  is a stick Bob made from 13,000 654  sticks that Chris Schuler built in his  Kentucky basement  that was amazing I never really knew  this was something you could do so is  Chris using some special kind of spring  stick trickery chris is not using any  tricks here this is just the power of  science and regular old tongue  depressors  the reason Chris can create this  incredible display is by leaving these  sticks into a very specific pattern the  real skill is to take a whole lot of  sticks weave them all together at once  so they're all held in place at three  different points when they're held down  in that pattern they Bend a little bit  and hold a lot of potential energy and  as soon as one of those three points is  released they fly off this is one of  those moments where it works and you're  hugely excited and then you realize  you've got thirteen thousand six hundred  and fifty four sticks to pick up